uh now we were told that the bank of
England would be releasing a statement
today we have just received it let me
take you through what we have the bank
of England says it is monitoring
developments in financial markets very
closely in light of the significant
repricing of financial assets it goes on
to say we welcome the government's
commitment to sustainable economic
growth and to the role of the office for
Budget responsibility the bank of
England says it will not hesitate to
change interest rates as necessary to
return inflation to the two percent
Target sustainably in the medium term in
line with the bank's remit the role of
monetary policy is to ensure that demand
does not get ahead of Supply in a way
that leads to more inflation over the
medium term the bank of England goes on
to say as the monetary policy committee
has made clear or make a full assessment
at its next scheduled meeting of the
impact on demand and inflation from the
government's announcements and the fall
in Sterling the bank of England says the
role of the monetary policy is to ensure
that demand does not get ahead of Supply
in a way that leads to more inflation
over the medium terms the bank of
England says it is monitoring
developments in financial markets very
closely in light of the significant
repricing of financial assets the
government has made a number of
important announcements and the bank of
England are taking measures to keep
abreast of that